hydrochloric acid is an example of a
strong acid and sodium hydroxide is an
example of a strong base
let's say we are titrating an unknown
concentration of hydrochloric acid with
a known concentration of sodium
hydroxide let's say it's 0.20 molar
because we know the concentration of
sodium hydroxide we call that the
titrant and because we don't know the
concentration of hydrochloric acid we
call that the analyte
and when our strong acid hydrochloric
acid reacts with our strong base sodium
hydroxide the products are an aqueous
solution of sodium chloride and water
as a quick review of how to write the
overall or the complete ionic equation
for a strong acid strong base reaction
remember that sodium hydroxide being a
strong base dissociates completely in
aqueous solution to form sodium cations
and hydroxide anions hydrochloric acid
being a strong acid will ionize
completely in aqueous solution to form h
plus ions and chloride anions
sodium chloride is a soluble salt so in
aqueous solution we would have sodium
cations and chloride anions and of
course we'd also have water
when writing the net ionic equation we
cross out these spectator ions so since
we have sodium cations in the left and
on the right we can cross out the sodium
cations and the same with the chloride
and ions so both of those are the
spectator ions what we're left with is
our net ionic equation so one way to
write the net ionic equation for a
strong acid strong base reaction is
hydroxide anions plus h plus cations
form water and our goal for the strong
acid strong base titration is to find
the concentration of hydrochloric acid
using a titration curve let's say we do
our titration and we come up with this
as a titration curve for titration
curves you put the ph on the y-axis and
the titrant on the x-axis so in this
case we're adding base to our solution
of hydrochloric acid and before we use
our titration curve to find the
concentration of hydrochloric acid let's
go through the titration curve and look
at some particulate diagrams and as we
look at particulate diagrams keep in
mind they're just to help us understand
what's going on in the actual solution
so they're just a representation and
we're also going to leave out
water molecules
for clarity purposes so let's think
about this point on our titration curve
so that's zero milliliters of base added
meaning we're starting only with
hydrochloric acid so there are two h
plus particles
and there are two chloride anion
particles
next we add in some sodium hydroxide so
the sodium cation is this purple sphere
right here and the hydroxide anion is
over here as well so we add in some
sodium hydroxide to our solution of
hydrochloric acid and for the hydroxide
anion that's neutralized by one of the h
plus ions that's present so the o h
minus and the h plus react to form h2o
and since we're leaving h2o out of our
particulate diagrams we don't see it in
this second particulate diagram what we
do see in this second particular diagram
are the chloride anions that were
initially present so here they are and
the other h plus ion that was initially
present and the added sodium cation and
since there's still an h plus cation
left in solution we haven't neutralized
all of the acid that was initially
present
so next we add some more sodium
hydroxide so here we're adding a sodium
cation and we're also going to add this
hydroxide anion to our solution the
added hydroxide anion will be
neutralized by the h plus ion that's
already present they will form water and
since we're leaving water out of the
particulate diagrams we don't see water
in this third particulate diagram what
we do see in our third particular
diagram here are the two chloride anions
that have always been with us in the
titration we had one sodium cation
already present and then we added one
more sodium cation so this third
particulate diagram represents the
equivalence point of our titration all
of the acid that we initially had
present has been neutralized by the
added base and we're left with an
aqueous solution of sodium chloride so
there are only sodium cations and
chloride anions in solution at 25
degrees celsius the ph of water is equal
to seven and since neither the sodium
cation nor the chloride anion will react
with water to change the ph
the ph at the equivalence point of a
strong acid strong base titration is
seven and we can find the equivalence
point on our titration curve by going
going over to a ph of about seven here
and if we draw a little dashed line
wherever that dashed line hits our
titration curve represents the
equivalence point so the first
particulate diagram was before any base
was added so that's this point on our
titration curve the third particulate
diagram is meant to represent the
equivalence point so this point on our
titration curve and our second
particulate diagram was when we haven't
neutralized all of the acid that's
present so that's in between those two
points on the titration curve
also notice how steep the graph is
around the equivalence point of this
titration therefore adding very small
amounts of base around the equivalence
point causes large changes in the ph of
the solution let's go back to our
particulate diagram at the equivalence
point and let's add some more sodium
hydroxide so we add one more sodium
cation and one more hydroxide anion this
time since there's no more acid to
neutralize the added hydroxide anion in
our fourth particular diagram here's our
hydroxide anion and one of these sodium
cations is the one that we just added
and we still have the chloride anions
and the sodium cations that were present
at the equivalence point so this fourth
particulate diagram represents the
titration after the equivalence point
when we're adding excess base
and we can see on our titration curve as
we continue to add excess base the ph
keeps increasing
now that we've gone through the
particulate diagrams for our strong acid
strong base titration let's get back to
our original problem which was to find
the initial concentration of
hydrochloric acid and we can do that by
figuring out how many milliliters of
base were added to get to the
equivalence point so if we just drop
down here on our titration curve we can
see that after 50 milliliters of base
have been added the equivalence point
has been reached
therefore it took 50 milliliters of our
0.20 molar solution of sodium hydroxide
to completely neutralize the
hydrochloric acid that was originally
present and if we know the initial
volume of the hydrochloric acid solution
let's say it was 100 milliliters we can
calculate the concentration using the mv
is equal to mv equation
so for our equation let's think about
acid being on the left side so we don't
know the concentration the molarity so
we make that x and for the volume of the
acid it's 100 milliliters so we plug
that into our equation on the right side
let's think about this being the base so
we know the molarity of the base it's
0.20 molar and we also know the volume
of base that was necessary to reach the
equivalence point which is 50
milliliters
solving for x we find that x is equal to
0.10
molar so that was the initial
concentration of our hydrochloric acid
solution and notice on our titration
curve remember we started with only
hydrochloric acid so we start with a
very low ph if we're titrating a strong
acid with a strong base as we add more
and more of the strong base the ph
increases
we've just looked at the titration curve
of a strong acid with a strong base
let's compare that titration curve to
this one which is the titration of a
strong base with a strong acid
since we're starting with a strong base
notice how the initial ph is very high
and since we're adding acid notice down
here on the x-axis it now says
milliliters of acid added
as acid is added we can see the ph
dropping slowly and as we approach the
equivalence point we see a large drop in
ph with small additions of acid however
the ph at the equivalence point is still
equal to seven so if we find a ph of
seven on the y-axis and go over to our
titration curve this point represents
the equivalence point and we could drop
down to the x-axis and we would see it
took 20 milliliters of acid to
neutralize the base that was initially
present
finally once we go past the equivalence
point we can see as we add more and more
acid the ph keeps getting lower
so this titration curve of a strong base
with a strong acid is essentially the
reverse of the first titration curve
that we saw which was the titration of a
strong acid with a strong base